hey what's up my name's Samuel lead in
this video I'm gonna be talking about
that which is value-added tax do you
need to be that registered do you need
to pay that what is that
so this was a little bit of an emotional
roller coaster for me because growing up
I didn't grow up around business people
I've started left school at 16 years old
with no qualifications and stumbled into
property became successful in property
and then very soon shortly after that
realized that suddenly that was a thing
so what that is is it's a value-added
taxes and it's an extra tax that's hit
on things and whether you like it or
whether you like it not you right now
will be paying that if you are not that
registered you'll be paying that
personally all of the time nearly every
business in the UK is VAT registered
most businesses and when you buy from a
business if you've ever bought a course
from me or if you've stayed at a hotel
or just pay for just pretty much
anything you're gonna pay an extra
twenty percent on top of what you buy
but you normally won't even know about
it because normally a company they won't
say to you the hotel is a hundred pounds
plus VAT they'll say the hotel is one
hundred and twenty pounds and you don't
even know that you're paying for the
hotel plus you're paying that the hotel
or whoever it is or if it's me as a
company will take your 120 pounds and
twenty pounds of that will give straight
to the Batman and then the hundred
pounds of course they're still gonna pay
tax on the hundred pounds as well so
that's what that kind of is now if
you're VAT registered here's the great
thing about being about registered if
you're VAT registered every time your
company or you buy something like a stay
at hotel or you buy I mean your mobile
phone bill even the VAT that's added you
can claim that back so if I go to stay
at a hotel and I pay a 120-pound I'll
say to them please could I have in that
receipt they'll give me the receipt and
it will show the VAT and then I'll then
ask the
the a-team and to give me the that back
now
that's the good thing the bad thing
about being back registered is you need
to pay that on everything so every time
you charge somebody for your product or
your service is you've got to add bat on
top so that's what that is now you might
be thinking now hmm do I want to be very
justed or do I not want to be about
registered because you do have a choice
however as soon as your turnover hits
85,000 pounds suddenly you do not have a
choice you have to be that registered by
law so I want to give you a warning
right now because so many of my students
are smashing that 80,000 pound turnover
threshold pretty quickly as well
now you might think 8,000 pounds a year
for my company that's quite a long time
away but it actually isn't because this
is 80 85 thousand pounds turnover not
profit so if you're in a business like
serviced accommodation where you're
getting a hundred pounds maybe a night
for the property and you're wetting out
20 times a month that's kind of adding
up you've got a few of those properties
your turnover is very quickly gonna get
to 85,000 pounds a year so if you're
getting close to the VAT threshold speak
to an accountant and make sure that you
become that registered it was a little
bit of a rollercoaster for me because
firstly I didn't even know I need to be
about registered I started my deal
source income but now sending lots of
deals and then something I was like
holy-moly I got to get VAT registered
and then suddenly it was like oh my
goodness I gotta add 20% on my customers
are gonna go mad I just increase my
prices by 20% and guess what no one
cared I thought I should have probably
increased my prices earlier so it went
from oh now to actually this is fine and
then when I realized that I could then
climb the that back on stuff now it's
fine so I've moved that register now for
years and it's all good
that's a mini crash course I hope you
found this useful if you did smash the
like button if you've got a question
around that comment below and if you
want me to do videos on any other topic
around property business finance
investments let me know what you want to
hear
about below in the comments and I'll do
my best you ask I answer thanks so much
also please give me a massive favour I
thought our all this content all I want
you to do in return is subscribe to the
channel so subscribe hit the
notification about and you don't miss a
video and if you want to watch more
videos you can check them out right here
and you can subscribe over here and if
you want to be mentored by me and my
team you can find out more about that in
the description below which is Samuel
365.com I'll leave a link in the
description see you next time